okay so uh ladies if we get started
right um
toxic femininity do does anyone know
what toxic femininity actually is
i'm gonna read it is it the toxic
version of femininity i'm gonna read
what
i'm gonna read what toxic femininity is
right
the signs to look out for on toxic
femininity is
lying for your own gain
giving misleading advice
mocking others
for their
their work or decisions trying to
manipulate situations to make others
look bad the term toxic femininity
refers to the gender expectations that
keep women subservient quiet and
submissive to men's domination and
aggression it also refers to when women
use their gender to obtain certain
privileges it is when
noxus indirect modes of confrontation
are masked with gentleness
do you know anyone that displays these
traits ladies
i mean you see her quite a lot with the
big topic in the moment with the pretty
privilege
thing so i feel like i can see that a
lot of girls using the pretty bluffish
to get into things like clubs
things like that
i don't know if it's necessarily a bad
thing have you never used pretty
privilege i mean i've noticed that i
know it's a difference when you come out
the house with makeup on without makeup
on this is a big difference between the
two
um
how do you use it your advantage i mean
i must sit here and tell the truth i
have i have before you know like
i think if you can you may as well as
sad as it is
i think like so i used to drive for
example so i was quite about to be there
speaking to the mic sorry
i used to drive so i was quite a bad
speeder and i think if you had a male
police officer compared to a female
police officer there was a big
difference really and i think that could
is anyone else who's pretty privileged
here
be honest ladies
it's fine to be honest
i mean probably but like i can't think
of a time when you know what i mean
do you think women get to use that over
men getting to use that
pretty privilege men have enough
what do you mean men having her men have
enough if girls want to i don't know if
they want to
show a guy off their assets to get
something as long as they're not trying
to deceive the person i don't see it as
a problem do you think that's
manipulation or do you think that's just
being like i said if it's nothing bad
coming out of it if it's manipulation
it doesn't really matter do you think it
like
it makes you it gives women like a false
sense of
what they think can happen if you're
just relying on your looks
like they can get you out of the
situation your looks can get us you're
thinking if you're pretty enough yeah
yeah yeah i mean you heard that saying
in it when people are like get your
boobs out yeah yeah get your tits out
like a lot of people's old men used to
say that as a joke and now we say it as
a joke what girls say get your tits out
well i i don't know i've said it in the
past
not to other girls like you know for
what reason for what what giving the
kind of [ __ ] people mocking the old
men that used to say it
right
hmm
that's interesting
so you you would tell ladies to get but
then no no no no i don't tell girls to
do that no but like if i'm in a group of
friends we'll be like mocking you'll be
like i'll get your tips out like it why
for what reason because we're mocking
advantages yeah
for the advantage what advantages work
yeah of course
this is hypotheticals no but it's in a
sense where you tell someone oh yeah get
your tits out it's like the idea of sex
cells in it so if i want something
yeah show a little bit of cleavage and
it's like you get you get a little
advantage in the situation so when she
was speaking about the privilege
sometimes it's not done like
um i'm purposely using that pretty
privilege if someone finds you pretty i
feel like they show you a little bit
more of attention or they give you that
little bit more subconsciously i think
that's within general like if a guy is
more handsome than the other he is more
entitled to get a little bit more from
the ladies or
get into a different opportunity or
different doors because of the way
someone looks because because because
i've been seeing it a lot that sometimes
you get into a door by just the way you
look rather than before you because
obviously before you even say anything
when someone sees the way you look they
think you look good they're gonna try
and approach you a bit more
do you think that's fair that you can
get into clubs for free and men can't
i mean there's a ratio in it
sometimes when you ask a guy and they
see there's a lot of man inside the club
they're like this is why there's so many
guys in here i mean i feel like the
promoters are just being clever with it
as well because it does bring guys in
having more girls there i mean so
so
you've used your pretty privilege have
you ever been there because this is
we're going to get back to it but it's
this is interesting for me like so have
you so when you use your pretty
privilege to an advantage right
you say again you don't really use that
really you don't no not too much all
right do you know women that do you
i mean i feel like people i don't know
specific people but i know that i've
seen it happen
do you know what i've noticed with women
yeah
like
do you know what i've noticed
no one ever no one's ever used it but
they know someone that's used it
do you even have it don't even that's a
bit coincidental but like you said
subconsciously yeah like
it just kind of happens sometimes you
don't really think oh i'm doing this now
but it's like just can't
instinct i don't know i'm pretty sure
it's been proven i swear
like it's like people treating other
people better because of how they look
like they're pretty privileged
yeah yeah yeah is that women just taking
advantage of men's men being simple
creatures
simple like um one of the girls said
they said that it's not a conscious
thing so sometimes it's more about the
effects rather than the intention going
into the action so i don't sit there and
think okay i know i can do this because
i'm pretty if i go and do something and
the consequence is different to how it
would be if i wasn't pretty so it's more
about how they react as opposed to how i
go into something
doing so you go into something normal
and then something yeah happens and
you're like oh
that only happened because i was dating
yeah so then what kind of psychology is
that put in you what kind of
does that give you confidence does it
like
i mean you don't really think about it
all the time like if it happens it kind
of just happened i'm not going in there
thinking okay i'm pretty this is going
to happen today so it's not really a
confident if i'm coming out knowing i'm
confident what it is already him doing
whatever the situation is doesn't mean
make me more confident if that makes
sense because i wasn't going to expect
that or i wasn't expecting whether it's
been done
but if i'm being honest if i've got a
situation and at the end of the day that
i've evaluated and it's happened because
i'm pretty if i go to that same
situation again i'll probably just egg
going a little bit more
it's being serious if i know if i've
gone even outside of prettiness if i've
gone to a situation where let's say my
money has helped me get into that door a
little bit more next time i'm going to
put a little bit more down because i
know it's going to get me a bit further
it's just using usually it makes sense
it's common sense right yeah in life you
want to use everything you have to to
you know to your advantage so that you
can get to as many opportunities as you
can so if if i'm if someone deems me as
pretty and the reason why i got that a
little bit more is because i'm just
pretty
then we thank god and move on
we thank god and move on
to your situation
it's just that simple there's no point
i'm trying to hide the situation but i
don't use it if you if someone whether
you don't think you're the prettiest
girl in the world if someone sees that
you're pretty and wants to give you this
little bag for free or they want to do
this take it and just go about your
business
[Music]
so
okay so do you think that um feeds the
female ego
i mean it must do yeah
for the majority of women i'd say yeah
but some women i guess they don't
actually care at all
to be honest we don't care about being
complimented and being full that they're
pretty there's probably a small amount
of people that don't actually don't care
but a lot of women yeah i guess i think
it comes down to moderation if you're
used to it then
at some point you just you don't really
pay attention to it just doesn't doesn't
really make much difference to you but
maybe if it's like you're not someone
who is you don't really go out a lot or
you're not used to having people
compliment you or treat you this way
then maybe the first few times that it
happens to you like oh actually
maybe you start to look at yourself in a
different perspective but if you're just
used to it then it's like you're just
second nature you don't pay attention to
it what if that second nature is your is
now your reality though do you know what
i mean so it may if if if being
pretty and getting
things just becomes your reality
because you're just used to getting
stuff because you're pretty do you think
that's feeding your ego